all the time I meet people who say I've
got a very good beginning but I haven't
yet got the end
they're wrong they haven't got a good
beginning
[Music]
so let's begin in the way that we intend
to do by asking each of our speakers to
set out their view about whether we
really do want more structure in life or
less structure in art and should they
reflect each other or do we actually
want to see structure in art when there
is none in life so Jana could I begin
with you and your thoughts
uh yes
um
I think basically life is chaotic
and yes we use all these various events
to create some kind of structure
I don't think it's a bad thing I think
events and traditions it gives us a
structure to deal with our emotions our
reactions for example burial rituals
um is a way to deal with grief when you
meet death
um questioning or name-giving of
children is a way to celebrate a child
and I I think those are important ways
to Mark changes and transitions in our
lives
um
I think
it is not an invention but a reality
that only after the end only after death
can our story really be told we don't
know who anybody really is or the
essence of somebody's life until we know
when and how they died who they were
when they died because some people
regret half their life stories or even
their entire life stories and values
just before dying and that does change
how we would see them that's why it's
important for example why even you know
I'm totally against the death sentence
but what it is interesting you let
people say something just before they're
executed because it is important do they
regret their actions or not you know
even though I hate the setup but there's
in a philosophical element to that and
um
the same then goes into fiction as a
novel writer yeah it would be great if I
could just you know write a bit left
right and go off but it would be very
uninteresting for others it would be a
little bit like having a conversation
with no threat
um yes we do jump from one issue to
another when we speak to each other yet
if it shall be an interesting
conversation there has to be some kind
of
um line in the conversation that leads
to a conclusion anecdotes are fun for a
little while but you want them to add up
to something and
there can be novels with no real ending
that are worth reading like Google's the
dead soul of kafkas the castles our
novels that petered out or in the in the
narrative sense because the writers
didn't have the time or opportunity to
finish them tightly and they are still
absolutely worth reading
um but I think that's because
in most narratives there's an art you
start building that Arch from the first
page and it only works if if it's
somehow
follows a structure that's it's laid out
generally in the first three sentences
you can no longer change that Arch if
you don't get it right from the
beginning
and then
you can almost see where it will go is
it going high and then load dramatically
it's a long thing but the ha it has to
follow that for us to feel it I think
though I cannot prove that but like
music has a mathematical structure in
terms of Harmony
which if it breaks it becomes like this
harmonic for us to listen to I do think
dramatic structure has the same that we
know with a pitch in our stomach what
works dramatically and what doesn't and
that summer has to be part of a
narrative to hold our attention can be
done many different way but it's that
kind of of here mathematical can you say
function has to be there
um yes you can do loads of other things
that can be fun for a moment but the
narrative
is important and I think actually it
doesn't matter if it ends with a whimper
or a bang because it depends how you
define that a wimpy can also be
could be considered a sexual kind of
thing that's a different kind of ending
but we do need to know what the ending
is to understand the entire story that
has been told us whether through a life
a theater play or a novel or in which
way that's my thank you I mean I'm
variance in what you say because
um
Wittgenstein when he was talking about
Freud instead of just criticizing the
view of positing unconscious thoughts
and desires he said Freud got things
wrong when he talked about dreams he
always tried to find an episode in life
that explained why the dream happened
and and Wittgenstein says that's not
what we want what we want to know is how
the dream ends when we wake up
so we're we're craving that narrative
structure it seems even Even in our
waking moments
David can I come to you next yeah well
this question has been answered by the
invention of a new art form in the 21st
century and it's called long-form
television and
um the hope of long-form Television was
that it was going to be like a 19th
century novel and that actually you
would get to know the characters and
every week your knowledge of the
characters would deepen and that as this
process went on the work would become
richer and richer now I don't know about
you but I have given up watching at
least four long-form series television
series because they're also boring
because they endlessly reiterate the
same question line of duty began
magnificently very fascinating it
invented a new kind of interrogation
scene and then by the first time they
did it great second time they did it
less great the third time they get it
you're screaming to get out of the room
I don't care who H is I don't think the
author knows who H is he's just
stringing it along because the idea is
meant to be that this series is meant to
go on forever and a lot of people watch
and show the BBC controllers are saying
can you please string this out and that
is what essentially long-form television
is it's stringing out ideas that go on
and on and on the other ones I've
stopped watching are the crown I got the
idea soap opera royal family got it okay
one series is enough to knock that idea
on the head you don't need to watch any
more of that Ozark the family are
apparently middle class Bourgeois people
but they're also Psychopaths and they
kill okay I got it I got it I got it
after two series I got it after three
series after four series again I'm
screaming it's enough the same ideas are
being endlessly rotated succession began
brilliantly original you know it's very
very witchy it's got some of the best
writing on television however how many
times can Brian Cox tell somebody to
off if he does it again I can't
stand it please stop you know and also I
don't believe it I don't believe there
is anybody like Logan right who goes
around and puts their face approximately
three inches from somebody else's face
off
don't know anyone who does that maybe
you and your richer lives have met
people like I haven't met anyone like
that I'm bored with succession and it's
dwindling and so you think of even the
greatest television series and the ones
that I'm fondest of in other words I'm I
was a fan of madman I was a tremendous
fan of high mats which is the German
series Homeland which is one of the
greatest television series made but even
the greatest fan of those series would
say that the end does not have the same
intensity as the beginning because they
were spun out for so long the only
exception to the rule you might argue is
The Sopranos the only one that works
like a 19th century novel and goes on
endlessly Reinventing the characters and
finding more richness in the characters
over I believe it's over a hundred hours
isn't it
um that I do believe but most people
during these series are screaming for an
ending they want an ending because they
want a sense of conclusion
now I'm asked to do a lot of literary
novels and adapt literary novels and the
first thing I ask is what is the ending
going to be
because by and large people who go to
the cinema leave the cinema remembering
the ending not remembering the beginning
all films begin well I've barely seen a
film that doesn't begin well the first
half hour is always entertaining the
second hour is usually a little less
entertaining and then by the last part
you're again going oh my goodness and so
all I ask when I'm given a book is does
this have a good ending
and the only
choice about the ending that I like is
please let it not be binary in other
words I am not I don't want to adapt any
book in which the question is will she
marry him or won't she will will the guy
get the job or won't he will the wave
Wipe Out the town or will the town avoid
the wave if there anything which has a
binary
a moment in the road at which there are
two choices
is something that I am in trying to
avoid at all possible costs because it
is untrue to most human experience that
such things happen and anyway those
audience those binary films in which he
either does or doesn't get the girl or
the girl does or doesn't get the job
piss half the audience off because they
want the other thing from the from the
half the most famous ending in history
which we all know as film fans is
Casablanca Casablanca is an improvised
ending where Humphrey Bogart and Ingrid
Bergman and Conrad White had no idea
which way it was going to end so it had
a binary ending and they discussed at
Great length how it would go and then
they invented the most magnificent cheat
in film history which is a speech in
which Humphrey Bogart has to say anyone
can see that the problems of two people
don't add up to a hill of beans in this
crazy world in other words those of you
who've been watching this film for the
last hour and a quarter a hour and a
half and wondering about whether Ingrid
Bergen is going to end up with me or
Conrad white it doesn't matter you
shouldn't you shouldn't have worried
about this in the first place now that
is a magnificent solution to the binary
problem but having said that it is also
a magnificent cheat and it's only
because it's so incredibly well written
that people don't notice that it is a
cheat
so endings are
well I'm going to quote Sandy McKendree
because Alexander mckendrick was not
only the Great film director who made
sweet smell of success and therefore is
one of the greatest directors who ever
lived he was also the pioneer of film
teaching and he said the most profound
thing about endings of anyone I know and
it was one of his rules for
screenwriters
and he said all the time I meet people
who say I've got a very good beginning
but I haven't yet got the end
he said they're wrong they haven't got a
good beginning
thank you
[Applause]
John you're a very hard act to follow
David I feel really
we're going to invite you to do it
nonetheless so please have you seen
Shameless
I'm amazed how much of this television
you've watched because I I don't have
the time I can't find the time but
I'm going to speak from the position of
a documentarian as a documentary
filmmaker because of course you know
you're going into the field of the world
of people's lives of situations where
you you you know that what you the
footage that you create is not going to
be the end there isn't an end you know
so you've got to find a way to make make
an ending in a situation that's ongoing
so I am I when I there is a sense of
filming and you say well that I forgot
I've got an end now now I can actually
make the film and and that is the truth
of it because I mean the end is is it's
got to happen and it's the end is a
fascinating metaphor as well it's more
than just the end of the film and one of
the things I was gonna thinking about
is like War and Peace and the moment
when Prince Andre lies on the ground and
he thinks he's dead or we think he's
dead
and it's it's almost the end is almost
somewhere in the in the beginning it's
planted it's an extraordinary moment
so you know endings do kind of echo echo
death in many ways
um and so they are crucial
um and then you know in terms of you
know I was thinking about the endings
that I'd enjoyed
um and in documentaries and I don't know
any anyone saw Frederick wiseman's film
about the New York Public Library called
ex Libras he has a beautifully crafted
ending which is very subtle but really
has this kind of pulse pulsating
question at the end of it and it's that
what you picking up on what you said
about death it's it's so true that the
death of a person makes their life clear
in a way that doesn't seem to the the
story of the life doesn't fall into
place until there is the death so eyes
are documentarian are trying to just I
don't I see myself as creating a
document in a certain moment of a life
or Grace Jones's life
um and it's going to go on or you know
the world of the films is gonna is going
to go on and what's that where does that
sit it's a question for me is quite an
interesting one where will this moment
of documentation sit within that world
or that life
so yeah endings do preoccupy those of us
who work in making films music to you
know theater they're crucial so I don't
want to I want the conversation to go on
I don't want to start speaking in
banalities
so I please this this is really helpful
uh to sort of set out some of the pieces
that we need to explore I'm I'm very
interested in the fact that Jan and it
surprised me you have a very sort of
Greek conception you know of the life
that the life is estimated at the end of
the life that you can only then evaluate
not not in the middle not before and and
you know call no man happy till he's
dead that's the idea that we get the
whole thing and yet and yet
um I'm thinking of check off short
stories where nothing much happens you
you there's a a long dry path there are
some cherry trees there's there's a
woman in a rocking chair she's looking
down the road maybe someone will come a
few things happen and nothing much
happens and it ends but somehow you know
exactly how their lives are going to be
how they've always been another going to
be so in some sense you don't even need
an ending you need the sense of the life
suggested by a slice of it maybe and I
wonder whether if we can talk about
documentary Making
it's not necessarily about ending the
subject but it's framing it in some way
that allows us to go on dwelling on it
thinking about it moving with it
somewhere yes so maybe an ending doesn't
have to be a dramatic ending like the
whole of the life maybe you can think of
how do I put artificial boundaries
around this topic that satisfy us as
viewers something like that yes I think
you know you you're setting up a series
of questions you're engaging in the
cognition of the viewer of the audience
and it's and you need to take them
somewhere and into spaces because we
exist in space I mean this is crucial to
filmmaking and in fact that's one of the
things that gets sacrificed a lot is
actually the sense of space because
everything's become so kinetic but you
know these details are really important
in the telling of a story in
storytelling but it's it doesn't need to
be a grand ending to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit iai.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas